What's a mission statement, and
how do you write one for your startup?
Let's define what a mission statement
is, what questions it should answer,
and then go over some guidelines you
can use to write one for your business.
So first, what is it?
A mission statement Is a statement
of your company's functions,
market, and goals.
The purpose of your mission statement
is to ground your big dream,
in terms of the steps you
plan to take to reach it.
You'll focus on what you're
capable of right now and
what you can achieve in the near future.
There's a few basic questions
that a mission statement
should be able to answer.
What do you do?
Who do you do it for?
And how do you do it?
Your mission statement should take
the vision you've created and
define what you plan
to do to achieve it.
So how long should your
mission statement be?
This is similar to a vision statement,
in that there's no set
length that it needs to be.
Some mission statements can
be a single sentence and
some can be a full paragraph, just make
sure you're providing the clarity needed
to give direction to you and your team.
Focus on the actual value that
you provide to your users.
For example,
Google's vision is to provide access to
the world's information in one click.
But their mission statement
is a little more specific.
Google's mission is to organize
the world's information and
make it universally accessible and
useful.
Do you see how their
mission statement describes
the way in which they plan
to achieve their vision?
They organize information and
make it accessible.
Try to provide a similar clarity for
your mission statement.
So, now that you know a little more
about the purpose of a mission
statement, take some time to come
up with one that you could use for
your company.